The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
We're going to get
started now.
For those of you who don't know
me, I'm Josh Slocum, one
of your TAs.
And today's lecture is going to
be a primer on ray tracing
to help you get started
on the final project.
So first, we're going to start
with a little background.
Tell you about ray tracing.
Ray tracing is essentially
a physics simulation.
You simulate the way photons
bounce around and interact
with materials.
And from that, you generate
an image of a scene.
It's extremely parallel because
you can trace a whole
bunch of photons bouncing
around at the same time.
And it has a huge capacity
for photorealism.
So like this sample seen here,
you have all sorts of
reflections and light working in
ways that you don't see in
a normal rendering program.
The final project, as you know
if you've read the handout, is
going to be groups of two
or three people each.
And you'll be given a working
ray tracer program.
A very slow one, but
one that works.
And your objective is to make
it run as fast as possible.
You can do pretty much anything
you want with a few
restrictions we'll
talk about later.
You can make algorithmic
improvements, parallelize it,
change the way the rendering
works slightly.
All sorts of things.
Pretty much anything
you can think of.
The only deliverables for the
final project are the
preliminary report due next
week, in which you'll have to
show us that you've profiled the
project, tell us what hot
spots you've identified, and
ideas you have for speeding up
the ray tracer, as well
as any actual work
you've already done.
The final project comes with two
built-in scenes that can
be ray traced.
Scene one, this one here,
is rendered much
faster than scene two.
And you're going to want to
work on that one first.
And then, there's scene two,
which is slightly different.
It has water and one
less sphere.
These are the restrictions
on what you can do
for the final project.
The purpose of these
restrictions is basically just
to make sure that everyone's
ray tracer is
doing the same thing.
So you're all working on the
same problem, and you're not
achieving speed ups by
simplifying out some
functionality of the program.
Does anyone have any questions
about the final project
before I move on?
All right.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
we're going to do a third scene
similar to the first
two, right?
PROFESSOR: Oh.
Yeah.
In order to make sure that
you're following these rules,
we're going to test your ray
tracer on one or more other
scenes and make sure that
they render properly.
But these are the two scenes
that you will be benchmarked
on for your performance grade.
All right.
Next, we're going to go over how
ray tracing works and the
big concepts used in the ray
tracer you'll be working on.
So the basic idea behind the
rendering is you're going to
construct a geometric model of
the scene you want to render,
and so it will be made
of polygons,
or spheres, or planes.
And then within that model, you
insert a grid of pixels.
They'll form the image you're
going to render.
And then, you just project the
scene onto the grid of pixels,
and you have some image.
The way you do this with ray
tracing is you use a method
called ray casting where you
take some camera and cast rays
through each pixel
onto the scene.
And then, whatever color object
the ray hits is the
color that that pixel gets
shaded in the scene.
This method of tracing rays is
called backwards ray tracing,
because you're going in opposite
direction that
photons go in when you're
actually observing something.
So if this was an actual
scene, you'd have light
bouncing here and
into you're eye.
Whereas what you're doing is
you're tracing backwards from
the eye to the object.
Ray casting--
this image here is
a ray image--
is very primitive.
It doesn't really
get you much.
So what you can do is you
can improve your physics
simulation by adding a whole
bunch more things on top of
it, like shadows, and
reflections, and global
illumination.
All sorts of fun stuff.
So if you want to start
simulating shadows, and
reflections, and defraction, you
need to start recursively
casting rays, which is
called ray tracing.
So when your ray bounces off of
an object, you can cast a
reflection ray at the same
angle mirrored from the
perpendicular of the object and
see what color object that
ray hits, and then, shade this
object with that color.
You can also cast a refracted
ray, and use Snell's a lot to
tell which direction it goes
in and do the same thing.
And then, you can cast a shadow
ray at all the light
sources in the scene.
And if the shadow ray hits an
object before hitting the
light source, then you know
that this object is in the
shade and make it darker.
And obviously, you have to limit
the recursion depth for
your recursive tracing, because
otherwise, you'll
never finish rendering.
So, first way of improving
lighting is to start using
direct illumination, which is
you have a light source at the
top of the scene.
And when you hit something like
a wall here, you then
bounce a ray at the
light source.
And depending on how far this
intersection A is from the
light source, you shade either
brighter or darker.
So it might be hard to see in
this light, but the wall gets
darker the further away
it is from the light.
And then, you do shadows the
same way, except at point B
here, the rate it bounces from
the ground hits this ball.
And so, point B is
in the shade.
Now, you can improve on shadows
by making what's
called soft shadows.
Soft shadows are shadows
that form a gradient
from darker to lighter.
They happen when you have a
light source that's not a
point light.
So if you look at the shadows
around you in the room, you'll
see there are gradients,
not just a
solid block of darkness.
And the way you achieve that
is when you get an
intersection, when your ray
intersects a point, you cast
multiple shadow rays at
different points along the
light source.
And depending on how many of
these rays hit something
before hitting the light
source, you shade some
proportion of the light being
casted, or the light coming
from this light source.
So you can see point D here,
none of the rays hit the light
source, and so, it's in
a very dark area.
Whereas point C, one of the rays
hits the light source,
and so it's in a slightly
brighter area.
And then reflection and
refraction work very similarly
to shadows, except instead of
bouncing from here to the
light source, you bounce off
this metal ball at the angle
of reflection.
And you bounce through this
glass ball using the angle of
refraction.
You can calculate using
Snell's law.
Any questions before
we move on?
All right.
So as you can see pretty clearly
in this image, there's
still some problems.
The ceiling is completely
black.
Shadows are mostly black.
And there's no light being
transmitted through this glass
ball either into the
shadow here.
So there's definitely some
improvements we can make on
our physics simulation.
The first thing we're going to
look at is called global
illumination, which is pretty
much any sort of illumination
that doesn't come directly
from light sources.
Now the reason this sort of
illumination is important is
that there's actually a lot of
light that gets bounced around
the room that doesn't
come directly
from the light source.
Like that white wall, if I shine
this laser pointer at
it, as you can see, there's
still a lot of light
bouncing off of it.
It's not all being absorbed.
So what you can do is you can
take your ray intersection,
and you can use what's called
the Monte Carlo method, which
is you take a whole bunch of
random samples and interpolate
those samples to get some value
that approximates what
the illuminant should be here.
The problem with that, though,
is that when you trace
backwards, you get this
exponential explosion of
recursively cast rays.
And you have no guarantee that
any of these paths will ever
get to this light source.
So what you have to do is trace
forwards, so you start
at the light source, and you
cast photons in random
directions and let them bounce
all around the scene until
they get absorbed.
Now, when a photon bounces, a
bunch of light gets absorbed.
But not all the light.
And so, the rest of the light
keeps reflecting.
And depending on the kind of
material, different amounts
and colors of light
will be reflected.
So as you can see, this
ray here bounces
off the orange wall.
And so, orange light
gets reflected.
This ray bounces off
the blue wall.
And so, blue light
gets reflected.
And this ray bounces off this
metal ball, and so it gets
completely reflected up
towards the ceiling.
So if you remember each bounce
in something called a photon
map, then later, you can come
back and say, oh, there's so
many photons in this area.
And that's what these
yellow circles are.
So the illuminance is going
to be approximately this.
The problem with that is unless
you're simulating an
extremely large number of
photons, you'll have an uneven
distribution.
So what you can do is you can
hybridize forwards ray tracing
and the Monte Carlo method.
So you construct your photon
map, which is represented in
this image by all the red dots
scattered everywhere.
And then you do backwards
ray tracing.
Then when you reach a point, you
randomly sample different
reflection rays and average
their illuminance to get the
illuminance at this point.
So you have blue illuminance
from the wall here.
And then light gray from here
and darker gray from here.
And the result is this sort of
pale blue, which you can't
really see in the image because
the light's bad.
Yeah, so backwards trace,
randomly sample, illumination.
And any questions
before we go on?
So it turns out even with
building a photon map and then
randomly sampling the photon
map, calculating the
irradiance can still
be very expensive.
So what we've implemented to
speed that up is what's called
an irradiance cache.
And the way the irradiance
cache works is there are
certain areas on objects that
will have pretty much the same
irradiance.
It's pretty much the same
irradiance levels.
So you can interpolate
from nearby points.
So what we do with the
irradiance cache is as the
scene is rendering, if there
is a cache miss, then we
calculate the irradiance for
some pixel which corresponds
to a point in the scene.
And then, if we then trace a
ray very near to that same
pixel, you can then interpolate
from nearby cached
irradiances and get something
that looks right.
So if you take a look at this
image, where the green dots
represent cache misses on these
big planer objects here.
There's very few cache misses.
And it's almost entirely
cache hits.
Whereas at the interface between
different objects, the
cache misses become
much more common.
But overall, the number of
irradiance calculations is
greatly reduced.
And then, the third kind of
illumination that we implement
is called caustics.
Caustics are just light being
lensed into patterns of
brighter and darker spaces, such
as you get from a light
pointing towards a glass ball.
Or if you ever see the sort of
wavy pattern on the bottom of
a pool, that's also
from caustics.
Caustics are also implemented
with the photon map, except
it's created slightly
differently.
Instead of bouncing photons
everywhere, photons are
absorbed as soon as they
hit a diffuse object.
So a photon might bounce off of
this metal sphere and then
hit the wall, and it will
be immediately absorbed.
Whereas if it hits this sphere,
it'll bounce, and
bounce, and then be absorbed.
So the objective of caustics
is to trace how photons are
grouped based on the optical
properties of
materials in the scene.
And then, caustics are rendered
pretty simply.
Because there's much fewer
photons than in the photon map
for global illumination, you
don't need to use an
irradiance cache.
So you simply trace a ray to
a point and then sample the
number of photons nearby.
And you end up with something
like this if you just do
caustics shading.
So then at the end, you take
your direct illumination, and
then add it to caustics, and
then add it to global
illumination.
And you get something that
looks like this.
Any questions before we go
to the code overview?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Do we weight
them equally?
PROFESSOR: So the
question was, do
we weight them equally?
And the answer is yes.
And you just sum
them together.
Ideally, you were clever and
constructed your ray tracer so
that they should be weighted
equally, because there's
weighting done internally,
basically.
So next, we're going to do a
quick overview of the code
that will be in your
repositories just get you
started and help you understand
how it works.
First, we're going to start by
explaining some of the classes
you'll find.
First is SceneObject, which is
the parent class for all of
the objects that will be used to
construct the scenes you'll
be rendering.
Every scene object has a ray
intersection method that's
called whenever you
trace a ray.
And it'll return where the ray
intersection is and the object.
And SceneObject is inherited by
these objects here, which
all of the objects will
inherit from.
Then we've got the Raytracer
class, which
contains the main method.
So it starts the program.
And it also contains methods for
constructing the scene and
then rendering the
scene once you've
constructed the scene first.
We have the LightSource class,
which is a base class for any
light sources.
In our ray tracer, the only
subclass is square photon
light, which is this light at
the top of the scene here.
And what that does, or what the
light class does, is it
contains methods for
constructing the photon maps
and getting illumination from
either global, or caustic, or
direct sources.
And then there's also the
iCache class, which
essentially just implements
the iCache for you.
Any questions?
So basic execution overview.
You have the main method
for Raytracer.
Parses the command line.
Constructs the scene.
And the scene is just a
command line switch.
So if you say S1, it'll
construct scene one.
If you say S2, it'll construct
scene two.
Then for each light source, it
tells the light source to make
photon maps for the global
and caustic illumination.
GUEST SPEAKER: I should mention
that we actually moved
the main functionality
into [INAUDIBLE]
so you can replace the data.
You don't have to touch that.
It just constructs the scene,
so that we can then add a
scene [INAUDIBLE] from that.
So you shouldn't need
to do that.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So that's changed then.
Then, main calls the render
function of Raytracer.
What the render function
does--
excuse me, method does--
is it casts a ray for each
pixel in the scene you're
going to render, finds the
nearest intersection, and then
computes the shading at that
intersection by recursively
bouncing rays and [? painting ?]
the illuminance
cache for illumination.
And that's basically what
the Raytracer does.
It's pretty simple.
So we're also going to quickly
go over how the light source
traces photons for direct
and global illumination.
The difference is kind of
settled, but pretty important.
With global illumination, you
want some total number of
photons to be put in the map.
And you put a photon in the
map whenever it hits some
diffuse surface.
And then, that photon then
continues bouncing around
until it's absorbed.
For caustic illumination,
it's pretty similar.
You have some set number
of photons you want to
get into the map.
You cast a ray in some
random direction.
And then, the ray intersects
with a diffuse material.
You store the intersection
in the photon map.
And then you break.
You don't keep bouncing
the photons around.
So that's basically it for
the code overview.
This slide has some resources
that you can use if you want
to learn more about
ray tracing.
Some of these will explain
concepts that we haven't
implemented.
They're an interesting read,
but not needed if you don't
want to read them.
And also, there's no standard
way of doing global
illumination or direct
illumination.
So you may come across resources
that do things
slightly different than our
reference implementation.
That doesn't mean either
one is wrong.
But you should be aware that
there will almost certainly be
differences.
Does anyone have
any questions?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So we can use one
of those alternatives?
PROFESSOR: Can you say
that louder please?
AUDIENCE: So we can use one
of those alternatives?
PROFESSOR: These aren't
implementations.
They're descriptions of
how ray tracing works.
You should not change your
code to work in this way.
These are just to help with
clarification if you want to
learn more about what's being
done in the code.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE]
what specifically are we allowed
to change for the
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: So what
specifically are
you allowed to change?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Which ever one's smaller
[INAUDIBLE PHRASE].
PROFESSOR: Anything not
prohibited by these rules,
which are paraphrased from the
project handout, you can do.
So basically, as long as you're
still performing the
same essential calculations,
you're fine.
Hmm?
GUEST SPEAKER: I would say the
criteria for correctness is to
look at the images, and
say that they look
more or less the same.
They don't give you a pixel
by pixel accurate.
This isn't a graphics class
that actually does that.
This should be almost
like a [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: They should visually
look the same.
If you find some approximation
that looks almost the same and
runs 100 times faster,
go for it.
You can't say, for example,
simplify your ray tracer
though by saying, OK, we're
only going to be able to
render these two scenes,
but we'll be able to
do it really fast.